hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep I'm your host grace Helbig
I'm very excited today we have Jameela
Jamil with us you know her from the good
place you know her from her activism you
know her from her Twitter account you
know that she's incredible we had such
great conversation about body positivity
her dealing with the world in general
also she had kidney stones the whole
time that she was here and she's such a
goddamn champion it was so lovely having
her enjoy this episode of not too deep
but Jameela Jamil well thank you for
being here thank you for having me
amidst all of the adversity constantly
trying to kibosh this I'm curious in
talking about Twitter you have an
interesting relationship with it oh
we're going straight in with Twitter
well such a strange relationship I do
too and I've fallen off from using
Twitter so much in the last like year or
so because it but I still look at it
constantly I still look at it for
information I look at it for news mm-hmm
but I'm very impressed by your ability
to be so candid on Twitter and I wonder
how that's changed or grown in the last
like few months or a year
oh I don't know I don't think I have
grown I think I just look I have I've
mixed results sure overwhelmingly I
think it's been a positive impact I've
had and you got to admit there's way
less deities and [ __ ] detox you doing it
being sold on social media are waves
have stopped pedaling laxatives to us as
much I've made it globally embarrassing
but I okay talked me through that moment
of you deciding that you're actually
gonna post something against this kind
of wave of you know superficial products
being pushed on everyone I started like
eight years ago when I got fat shamed
back in England
to be a TV host there
and so I was currently on the radio at
the time and people became obsessed with
my weight and I was like what do you
play why do you need to just know I'm
thin over the airwaves it wasn't even
filmed Wow
so anyway so I so I've been talking
about this for years but the diet and
detox tea thing wasn't mainstream until
2018 right and me it became major and it
became acceptable and it became part of
quote-unquote wellness culture and so I
I think it was a Kim K posts that I saw
where she was pushing like appetite
suppressant lollipops and the
advertising was all you know targeted
towards young girls no ink and
everything about it just offended me and
so I didn't have very big following and
I did tell her to [ __ ] off
[Laughter]
abrasive like I questioned my abrasive
language I don't question why I did yeah
in retrospect sure the choice of
language could have been different but I
think the intention behind the message
is valuable
absolutely but look I I also I so while
I do good on Twitter and I think that I
help to make women feel seen and
different people feel seen or I think
that I'm able to make people feel less
alone in their own mistakes because I've
made so many of my own and I'm so open
about them I also know that I [ __ ] up
sometimes and that just comes from the
fact that I am ignorant and I humor is
gonna be ignorant a bit
yeah and I'm always going to be trying
to undo that and trying to learn and I
and I just wish that I would think
before I tweet but I just I I guess
since I had a nervous breakdown when I
was younger and since then I kind of
made a deal with myself that if I was
gonna stay on this earth and not kill
myself
I was just going to be honest all the
time about everything that I thought
that's I think that's very refreshing
especially when it comes from a place
you can tell with you that your
intentions are good that your message
means well and you have no intention of
trying to
belittle any sort of or marginalize any
sort of group that you're really elusive
inclusivity and that resonates I'm also
a comedian and a [ __ ] idiot so it's
like having all the passion and the good
intention and having a comedic mind and
being a [ __ ] idea as a cocktail is a
nightmare I find it so enjoyable cuz I'm
like this is a real human woman like
yeah well that's just it that's what it
is it's just like you know what men get
away with [ __ ] all the time and say
whatever they want they do whatever they
want they beat whoever the want the [ __ ]
they want up and we just let them we
just let them get on whereas with women
we kind of we have put this pressure on
women just to feel as though we have to
be at all times
omniscient to all nurturing all
forgiving and perfect yeah and I don't
subscribe to that I believe in the sort
of Natalie Portman theory of [ __ ] up and
thrive yeah and so I believe in being
allowed to be fallible I believe and
being allowed to make mistakes I don't
believe in being embarrassed about
ignorance if you're doing everything you
can in your power to undo it and I know
that's the best example I like being
unfiltered especially as a brown woman I
feel like it's really important that
young people see that you're allowed to
say whatever [ __ ] comes into your head
sometimes obviously don't be a bigot or
an [ __ ] but I think that we just need
to be able to get everything off our
chest and also women in particular I
think are less practiced ban mmmm-hmmm
at saying there's no how we feel about
things really and then when when you're
seeing a woman that is outspoken or does
speak her mind
it's like blanketed in this negativity
from people that like it's too much oh
yeah I get called a bit much all the
time and I feel way to master being able
to change to create like mass change
someone would have done it by now
everyone who's ever created change has
been [ __ ] annoying everywhere that's
very true and so I am annoying but I
also like I'm not really interested in
popularity I'm not I didn't get into
this to make friends I've got 12 friends
like Jesus I don't need any more friends
the Internet to like me I just need
change to happen so that if I choose to
have kids there
not going to walk into this [ __ ] show
that we are in that's really refreshing
and nice to hear especially it's just a
freeing sensation to to just be
authentically yourself because in the
position that you're in right now I can
see the pressures of it going either way
of like having to give messages that are
super polished and very you know like
unrealistic in a way or very
conservative in the way and it's nice to
see you just ripping off band-aids and
being like [ __ ] it this is how I am this
is what I think and I'm gonna let you
know and take it or leave it and I try
stuff out yeah sometimes I just want to
see where our conversations gonna go I'm
a maniac no I just tweet something
devices I just see what's gonna happen
do you when you wake up in the morning
and you look at your phone like we all
do but I'm sorry did you hear that
because I think I heard it and I didn't
hear but congratulations Bobby it's
processing a lot of things right now
when you wake up in the morning you look
at your phone for the first time what's
the first thing you do on it do you go
to Twitter do you check Instagram do you
not look at your phone first thing in
the morning
I think I do look at my phone first
thing in the morning and I normally
check Twitter moments
yes that's my news source aim I did want
to say something go about outspoken
women might even just outspoken women
just third I wanted to know your take on
this there we have a cycle yeah like a a
cycle a lifeline for women of about a
year and a half to two years of
popularity
have you noticed weed with everyone
across the board then unless a woman
disappears into obscurity she will be
dragged to within an inch of her life
and it doesn't have to be someone
outspoken like myself or someone who
challenges the monarchy like mega mark
oh yeah so just be Anne Hathaway who
made a couple of speeches that people
didn't like yeah and she was torn and
you [ __ ] by the internet she was kind
of the first ridiculous cancellation
that we really saw yeah and then
Jennifer Lawrence everyone's like she's
so funny and relatable oh my god she's
just like us and then a year and a half
later it more oh why is she trying to be
so funny and relatable all the time
she's not like us she's faking falling
over and the vitriol and hatred towards
I was so interesting and so when I was
on my car
like over the last two years and I start
seeing articles like trees for feminist
era we need I was like this is exactly
what you don't [ __ ] one is you can't
control yeah you get put on this
pedestal that you haven't climbed up
onto yourself right and you get hyper
overexposed
mm-hm and then you are at such a height
that is perfect for being kicked off of
and falling all the way down so
thankfully for me I don't take any of
this [ __ ] personally as soon as I was on
the come-up I was like well this is
going to be here we go [ __ ] brutal
but I was always ready for it so that's
why I've never altered my behavior I
still speak like a sort of inmate but
the fact that you even thought about
that the fact that you've kind of
pinpointed that theory and that ideology
of the life line the life of a popular
woman right that you've had yeah I think
a lot of people will get surprised by it
because they haven't thought in those
terms before like seeing it almost from
the outside and knowing and then when
it's like bestowed upon you you know
exactly what this is
I'm not crazy though that's right no
you're not crazy
I think you menage like I think you're
just a social noticer I think you've
watched and like because your background
right you've been radio you've talked
about pop culture you've been you've
rented us when I was young right I've
written in magazines so I think you have
an innate ability to see social trends
to see how like the hive mind works in a
way which I'll is vet really valuable
and I think helpful for you to keep that
that like ability to distance yourself
and not take on all of the hate you
might I didn't take on any of the love
either coming at me I was just like no
it's not real it's not gonna hate comes
in it's the same thing it's just like
it's all because I think you're grounded
I think I've downs you in a sense that
you're you see yourself as a real person
you have humility to yourself
you don't take yourself so seriously but
you are that doesn't take away from your
passion about ideas and thoughts and
messages yeah and I think that you can't
teach that so coo
to you for developing that over time I'm
messy and I embrace my own mess but I
think that's the message to young women
that is so valuable because when I was
growing up I mean I read that you were
very shy growing and I was too and I was
very insular and very afraid of like
social situations and that sort of thing
and I didn't have anyone to idolize that
was messy that was like still horrible
5ik everyone was perfect it was also you
know I grew up pre-internet like
internet was just getting developing how
old are you I'm 34 same okay yeah so it
was a the same kind of timeline of as it
develops and you have more accessibility
to see people's real lives and to see
and first celebrities to access you know
the real world more directly then you
start to see all these like fallible
things about people for better or worse
if that like resonates with you in some
way I feel awful for the the limelight
that gets thrust on you as soon as you
start speaking your mind about something
then now you are the champion activist
for all women but they do it they don't
know but also I think the tear down the
take down with outspoken women like
Toronto Burke or myself or any activist
like Greta tunberg I think that is
mostly to send a message to other women
yeah around the world of like don't
speak out control thing
yeah don't speak out because will will
will go and will humiliate you will
write smear campaigns against you like I
have crazy rumors about me on the
[ __ ] Internet my family get dragged
into that [ __ ] like your pictures of my
disabled family members with them being
ridiculed and like all over the internet
because they'll do anything at any cost
to shut me up because I speak
effectively about an industry that's
worth billions of dollars the toy
industry that funds the media industry
and I also talked a lot about abortion
I'm pro-choice in here and this is a big
year yeah us making sure that we
maintain women's rights yeah in the
United States and so they wanted to shut
any anyone who's you know Greta
threatens the oil industry and the class
tear industry
so you know you've so they they try to
tear you apart to make you an example
for other women mm-hmm yeah that's not
even try it's really interesting and so
I guess that's kind of why I just feel
that it is my duty to continue well do
because I feel like there may be [ __ ]
nightmare makes me so happy to hear in a
way because a lot of people would you
know bend to all of that pressure and
Bend all of that hate and Bend to all of
that like you know negativity put on you
to shut you up and instead your ability
to kind of look at it humorously cuz
that's I've been making stuff on the
internet for 12 years now and so every
possible terrible thing has been said in
a comment somewhere about me and it you
know affects you on certain days and
some days that's easier to look at it
and realize like oh hurt people hurt
people like this is coming from a place
of insecurity or negativity or something
like that and I can distance myself from
that and look at this like it's really
funny that this angry man took this time
to Photoshop and then when I imagine
them sitting in their computer in the
dark like doing crude Photoshop I'm like
that's just purely ridiculous so I can't
take offense to this because like you
clearly have some other deeper [ __ ]
going on that I can't fix yeah yeah I
used to troll celebrities famous as well
like it was like a teenager
in the dark o-22 and I used to talk [ __ ]
about people all the time Miley Cyrus
Drake Rihanna like even the Queen
herself beyond try to talk [ __ ] about
people all the time cuz I I was mentally
ill yeah I was unwell I was bad I was
angry sad I was angry I was overcoming
trauma and you know he would just you
would look at these incredibly
privileged people and just think well
they're not gonna read this right right
not gonna see my article my stupid hot
take on their music video like and then
you get here and you meet them in person
because you're a real human being your
real feelings and you see it all and now
that I am the victim of like similar
trolling stuff like I just think I
[ __ ] deserve it I remember what
headspace I was in yeah and so I know I
know what it's like just to be angry and
to have nowhere to direct it so you
direct it where you think it's not
actually gonna hurt anyone right that it
does [ __ ] hurt people it adds it
piles on to the situation yeah but
that's kudos for you for recognizing
that and admitting that because I think
a lot of the people that still struggle
with [ __ ] on people it's because
they haven't recognized or like admitted
that they're sad or they're in a bad
place I know that we're not supposed to
get to date to get incredibly real and
one of the things that I used to do is I
didn't know what slut-shaming was I
thought slut-shaming when I was younger
was just saying a woman couldn't have as
much sex as man mmm whereas I've always
thought women should have as much sex
that they possibly can really people as
they can i I but I used to be quite
slut-shaming me about like the way that
I would discuss women who would always
be very nude in their videos and the men
would be fully clothed and I didn't know
how to perfectly articulate my feeling
and my feeling was really just why are
the women always doing it and the men
get to wear full fully clothed why am I
not seeing some balls I want to see some
balls or articulated it also thinking I
was being funny in this very
slut-shaming way and also I was her I
was angry with women who had sexualize
themselves now yeah a year before I
started speaking out about that sort of
stuff I'd been raped okay and so there
was something switched on in me where
after that happened where I I just I
lost control of myself I started to feel
so mad women who I would see sexualizing
themselves I started to blame them for
the reason that I was so heavily
sexualized men even if I wasn't
projecting anything sexual right that
they'd whipped men into a frenzy to
think that we're all just like hoping
for sex all the time or we are all just
sexual objects nothing more that was
completely unfair of me yeah I was just
young ignorant yeah dramatized and
that's how it came out and so I think
we're seeing just we're gonna see so
much trauma play out on the Internet in
the next four months oh that's because
now the state of the world everyone in
their quarantine has nothing to do but
face themselves and have access to the
Internet and they're also losing their
jobs and they're potentially you're not
going to be able to put their kids
through college or they're going to lose
their homes like people I know can't
even make rent right now they can't pay
for their health insurance it's like the
REA the global rage pandemic is the next
one that's coming straight after Corona
they're gonna be so angry there's gonna
yeah there's gonna be a lot that's what
I was worried about yesterday I was
talking to some friends and just like
the scope of the mm affecting the scope
of it affecting everyone's mental health
mm-hmm I'm very curious about and a
little scared for it's gonna be like the
[ __ ] purge completely understandably
in fact so many people were failed by
their governments right and so yeah it's
gonna it's Twitter's gonna be a really
dangerous place I think over the next
couple of months and people have been
tweeting me being like you're being
awful quiet right now and I'm like yeah
man I'm just [ __ ] I'm deal I may have
been dealing with my reaction to what's
happening in the world
I'm not stupid like this is an
inflammatory time where if you get on
the wrong side of people yeah even a
couple of people in in privilege do this
week yeah there's been a lot of even the
imagined video that went up yesterday
Vanessa Hudgens saying the Vanessa
Hudgens thing which also blew my mind
because that was post that was live
streamed and then apologize for all in
the scope of like three hours yeah that
was like every major celebrities
publicist is like at home being like oh
no don't go live don't go live you don't
have a screen
and how do we control what your message
is to everyone but it's just I'm just
I'm just gonna observe because right now
this is a very emotional time for people
well you've also been doing in parallel
with you know hacktivism Harry stuff
yeah handedly I mean you have a new
podcast coming out and this episode will
go up before your new podcast comes out
can you tell us like the the scope of
the podcast so two years ago I started a
movement called I way and it was weirdly
movement that I started accidentally in
defense of the Kardashians what's
happened to our relationships in
surprised me this picture of them all
the whole family all the women of the
family with numbers written across their
body and the numbers weren't how much
money they've earned or you know what
they've achieved it was just how much
they weigh and once I clicked on that
one picture because the algorithm
suddenly thousands more pictures started
to turn up for my explore page on
Instagram Selena Gomez how much she
weighs Taylor Swift how much she weighs
there's probably a picture of you and
how much you weigh I found a picture of
me and my fake weight and so I tried to
find pictures of men that had the same
numbers written across their bodies and
I couldn't if you're not UFC fights and
no one cares about how much I weigh no
one explicitly no one cares yeah so I
one day tweeted what I weigh out into
the world I was like I weigh my
financial independence my orgasms my
friendships my you know activism
whatever and it started a movement that
I thought would last about three weeks
like the ice bucket challenge and now
two years later we have a million
followers on Instagram and it's
completely global and recognized by the
royal family in the UK and government
and we're changing global policies and
we're starting to work on bills to
change actual legislation to protect
young people from things like diet
products and Photoshop
height and weight discrimination but the
Instagram account is only so much as
only so much I can get out there so I've
decided to expand the Instagram account
into a YouTube channel which is
launching in a couple of weeks god help
me
and and a podcast and so if the aiwei
podcast that we're starting that's great
imminently and it's got people like
Roxane gay and Gloria Steinem amazing
Neal Brennan friend yeah Aisling B so
it's just full of funny and smart and
inspiring people that's great and it
also must be nice for you because you
know on social media we have to curate
our messages within such a capacity that
to be able to just speak unedited ly and
ask questions freely on a something like
a podcast must be a really nice platform
well yeah and also it's basically a
mental health podcast people think that
aiwei is a body positive movement
because of its beginnings but really
it's just become a mass mental health
movement right you know we talk about
LGBTQ and disability and all kinds of
different things and race and so my
being able to talk about shame and
mental illness with all these inspiring
people is just gonna teach me cuz I'm
[ __ ] ignorant and I need to learn and
so if I'm gonna learn I think it's
selfish to do it privately so I can just
come out and impress everyone with how
intelligent learn with everyone else and
we can all you know heard education I
think that's great you're including
everyone in the educational process of
it all yeah I think that's wonderful
how have the episodes been going so far
good I mean I don't listen to any
podcast because I haven't had any time
I've been on podcast I've not listened
to them so I don't actually know if it's
nothing to compare it to and so I hope
it's gonna be good I've enjoyed the
chats I learned a lot so if this was
just my own personal hobby then that's
okay okay but some of them have been
incredibly moving and I I like it good
and that's all that matters that
resonates okay we're in take a quick
break when we get back we have more not
to D we'll be right back
[Music]
obviously we all know that life is
stressful and difficult and we could all
use some help sometimes but we may not
know how or where to ask for it and
that's where better help comes in there
online counseling offers licensed
counselors who specialize in issues
including depression and anxiety as well
as complicated relationships family
relationships sleeping grief stress
trauma and anger you can schedule secure
video or phone sessions with your
therapist plus securely exchange
unlimited messages simply fill out a
questionnaire to help them assess your
needs get matched with a counselor and
start communicating in under 24 hours
and if for any reason you are unhappy
with your counselor you can easily
request a new therapist at any time for
no additional charge
get professional help when you want it
wherever it's most convenient and not
too deep with grace helbig listeners
will get 10% off their first month with
discount code grace that's better help
calm / grace why not get help better
help calm / grace you and your boyfriend
are adorable you're very sweet and you
tweeted out something that resonated
with me hard the other day about during
this quarantine you have to really like
the person yet you're with not just love
and I was like this is very true like I
love my boyfriend but I also like him a
lot and that makes this situation a lot
easier to deal with it's gonna be like
The Hunger Game yeah it's gonna be awful
there's gonna be such a big divorce boom
at the end of this oh that's what I said
the day - into quarantine Ozai do you
know how many people are breaking up
right now because they literally can't
deal with the other person that they're
with right now yeah it's fascinating so
how did you guys meet each other you've
been together five years we were both
DJs you're both DJ is both DJs and we
met at BBC Radio 1 in the Live Lounge
and became friends and then I was just
about to move to Los Angeles and I was
telling him that and he was like no way
I'm also moving to Los Angeles Wow in
February and I was like wow that's so
crazy
I only found out about six months later
that was a lie he intended or moving to
Los Angeles he just panicked and said
whatever he had to say is alive keep
hanging out with him and then when I
moved he moved over with me really yeah
and never left
oh you moved in together when you moved
over yeah Wow
pretty much what a love story yeah we
hung out we were just living in each
other's pockets and so yeah that was it
we he was living in Rick Rubin studio
core and so I went and stayed there with
him and then we fell in love that's
amazing we are best friends and we
started as best friends you can tell
that you guys are our buds like yeah
that's really sweet to see that and it
makes sense that you started out as
friends first and then like love
developed it was like that feeling you
know when you meet someone at school and
you're like oh wait we're gonna have
lunch together
exactly it's that feeling of relief
that's the feeling I got when I met him
and so so it's just I'm stuck indoors
with my best but if what a tragedy and
he's got fortnight and I've got Wi-Fi
yeah how's it been have you guys
developed a situation do you any code
words of like needing space no we this
is how we live anyway introvert this is
a quarantine is just a weekend it's an
extended weekend you've been prepping
for this unintentionally for a year my
whole life yeah so no we are fine and
you know we're just we really like each
other oh that's great really funny if
one of us is murdered a big section of
this podcast how's it been cuz you guys
have been together through this whole
like trajectory that you've had how has
that been for the relationship fine I
mean he's just super supportive and he's
really got my back and he's been
learning a lot I guess he has been
learning to understand his own privilege
and understand how to be an ally and
learn about other experiences and read
different books by writers that he
haven't you
read before and so I think it's just
been fun and we've both been learning
together and I think he finds it more
painful than I do when the internet
tries to tear me a new [ __ ] but he
started to learn I really don't give a
[ __ ] to be so support always so he's
like going through all of the comments
no he's he's a great ally and I think we
just have each other's backs and it's
been a very it's been a crazy couple of
years for both of our careers and it's
really great to go through this as with
a witness to your life that's that must
be so anchoring in a way yeah have that
person that you've met before you know
everything kind of started to steamroll
and then for him to still be there and
supportive is really sweet take us
through the you didn't do much acting
before zero acting zero yeah so how take
us through the the how did how did it
happen how did acting happen for you
then I did not have sex with anyone if
that's what you're asking no no no I
don't even cross my mind any person who
would [ __ ] my way to the bottom I was
signed as a writer two three arts three
arts for making the good place they
needed an overly tore annoying English
Indian and so they sent me for the
audition I didn't think I should go
because I don't have any acting
experience and I had to dance and was in
it and I was like this is this is not
but they emotionally blackmailed me into
going and so I was like [ __ ] it I'll get
to meet Mike sure I went yeah I I got I
had to audition with Mike Wow for 15
minutes Wow
and he was like you can do improv right
and I was I did a kind of Fanny Brice
can I do improv yeah I had to improv
with the great and iconic Mike for 15
minutes in order to get that role not
intimidating at all just terrified
terrified
he was so great and supportive and
wonderful and that maintained for the
whole time on the good place but I don't
know why he gave me that job there were
women who were much more famous and and
interesting and talented up for that
role who would have been way less messy
on Twitter but I I got it and I just did
my best to keep up amazing I mean that's
so I mean once you're in that whirlwind
I'm sure it's hard to like see from the
outside how everything is going oh yeah
it's been crazy for you guys how I mean
it's just ended so like how has the
trajectory been like have you had a
second to reflect on all of it or is it
just like everything it's all [ __ ]
isn't it do you know what I mean yeah
it's I'm very lucky for the things that
I have and things that I get to do but
none of this means anything and I also
I've had chronic health conditions since
I was a kid and I think that there's
something about that that sets your
perspective differently to other people
we're really just basic health no matter
what award I'm winning or what party I
get to go to I still wake up and pain
every day I still go to bed every night
in pain and swollen like I so my my
gauge of what happiness or success or
good things are and relies mostly on my
health and my mental health
so yeah yeah it's fine but it's also
just an industry that's full of a lot of
very strange people yeah I'm a fellow
introvert so like you're going out to
parties and award shows and things like
that I'm like god bless you too our
queue for the red carpet oh yeah have
you had like are there any standout
party stories that you are situations
that you've been in I mean there's one I
talked about it I think on a on a chat
show I I went to the big Oscar party the
UTA Oscar party I'm with ETA and so I
was allowed to be there this is really
this is pretty good place and I knew who
I was
everyone just thought I was an
overconfident Geena
walking up to a list celebrities channa
just start small talk hand me a glass
after a while I just [ __ ] off to the
buffet which is always where you have to
go as an introvert yeah and just eat
your feelings yeah and I saw loads of
delicious steaks I had one I thought it
was one of the best steaks that ever had
went back I was like you know what I'm
just I'm gonna I have no money I'm gonna
put these in my freezer
so I piled ten steaks one on top of the
other top of the other the other I was
standing in a cute I had Gwyneth Paltrow
in front of me Edward Norton behind me
and Gwyneth turned around at one point I
looked at me and I was at Cannes and
then she gave me a beam of such approval
back around and went about her day so I
then took the steaks into the garden and
I just flipped them over into a cloth
napkin bound up the napkin because the
stakes of bloody so like creates a glue
and then I shoved the steak mound okay
under my skirt in between my thighs and
just as you slowly waddle and no way out
of the party and I was whirling so fast
and so nervous because I could feel the
blood starting to drip down my inner
thigh had come on the worst period of my
life and I accidentally knocked over our
Pacino and then I state sort of like
flew out from under my leg across the
floor with this blood streaked across
the floor I went and just grab the
steaks didn't even do a dress out
grabbed the steaks got up and ran out of
the party and then texted the people who
taken me just saying hey sorry I had to
run home there's an emergency and but I
hope they catch that weird guy who
knocked over the lead singer of Muse who
I used to know from being an interviewer
back in England and he was like hey do
you want to come to this party with me
it's like Leonardo DiCaprio Andrea
having a body and I was like I'd love to
I've just been through so much I went
home and I am on my own
Wow they lasted like two weeks I put
them in the freezer I'm non idiot and
that's an incredible life hack for
people to know what steel party steel
party yeah no one's eating them they're
just gonna go in the garbage it's so
devastating and no one doesn't eat them
especially at Hollywood parties cause
everyone's been on a diet since the 80s
right and everyone's wearing something
so expensive that they even thought of
getting dripped on in anyways yes Shane
but that makes me very proud of you
thanks a lot of guts to follow through
with that mission I think I would have
just cancelled it at some point
I know probably the owl push nothing
almost nothing I wouldn't do for nothing
changed I don't think ever well I think
it's still the thing that rouses my
interest the most any given supermarket
that's my happy place oh the good place
for me would be a giant supermarket
really do you have a preference over UK
supermarkets first American supermarkets
uh I think the candy in America is trash
really I'm sorry
Wow and the chocolate is disgusting as
well [ __ ] disgusting corn syrup is
the devil it just tastes too sweet and
stuff here is too sweet but candy aside
cuz I think England have got that we've
got that down our biscuits are perfect
we have nailed moderation of sugar but I
think I am I'm just into the American
supermarket way oh yeah I'm totally into
it the aisles are bigger those movie
it's so exciting I mean I don't think
I've ever felt more fulfilled than I did
but I do walking around American
supermarkets like a theme park I mean
they're bringing back supermarket sweep
I feel like you'd be a great contestant
oh my god I want to host that show it's
one of my favorite game shows growing up
as a kid that I'm like oh I can't
believe they're finally bringing it back
way overdue says every time we needed it
it's now also just it looks like
supermarket sweep like every [ __ ]
this is like they took the six hams and
the six turkeys everyone's taking their
maximum amount of everything the are you
into a great British baking show no I
was on it once okay how was that I was
bad it was about I hated it me is way
out of my league I know my limits that's
it's too precise it's too scientific
I think the Guardian maybe did 10 the 10
worst moments the bake-off and I was
four of them everything my dessert was
the dessert first dessert in the history
of the bake-off deemed unsafe for
maryberry see that's an amazing honor
I had a full-on meltdown like it really
pushes you and you stopped and I'd never
baked before Oh see you don't really
know how much experience I'd had with an
oven because ever was more of a Mike
microwave gal I make eggs you make eggs
in the microwave I did for many years
okay explains my brain yeah I yeah you
just are so disgusting I'm so sorry
a little bit of olive oil in and you put
the eggs in you bake the eggs and then
you pop it in the microwave
20 seconds take it out stir it around
again and you get really fluffy I mean I
believe you I'm actually making home and
try this
it's very carefully deeply carcinogenic
it's how I it's how I I don't know
amazing how I survived my team I feel
like there's a cookbook in the horizon
on the horizon yeah well it needs more
more of me but what a what what's next a
lot of you wants to want to know what's
next I know you're working on the
podcast it's coming out I don't know
it's the [ __ ] apocalypse
I don't know cuz next I guess what's
next is we have all this great content
coming out on YouTube that is
just full of the most interesting and
inspiring young activists and doctors
and surgeons and therapists and we're
talking about sex and gender affirmation
surgeries and now and mental health and
the environment and everything so I
think that's really cool that's coming
out and the podcast and then I'm gonna
I'm gonna see if I could write a book
good it feels like the right time I feel
I'm gonna get in so much trouble they
can help hone no-one can curtail yeah so
I guess I guess writing is something I
want to do and also the show that got me
signed in America is a show that I want
to start working on again to maybe write
amazing what else are we gonna do well
you came out here as a writer that's
what I mean so I think I met finally
write and say you know take try and take
this moment to work out how I can
service other people's needs and then
also be creative myself
that's great not very much time to be
creative because it's a [ __ ] lot of
time I can't imagine and it takes up so
much brain space to that the creative
part of your brain has to kind of sit
dormant for a second well yeah and also
you just feel responsible for so many
different people and so many different
problems and there's just always more
problems and then once you speak out and
one thing other people want to speak out
on everything yeah it just because it's
been very very stressful to manage on so
you know what do you do to de-stress
like what do you watch if you have time
to watch things oh I just watch the best
TV show on Netflix could feel good oh
it's so good yesterday's a tional
accession of perfect I'm giving it a ten
out of ten Wow yay what's the premise
it's the premise is just a young female
gay comedian going into a relationship
with a straight girl and just how
they're mastering that relationship it's
by May Martin and it's just that the
performances are just stunning Lisa
Kudrow's in it which is incredible and
so I'm watching that the comeback Curb
Your Enthusiasm crashing by Phoebe Walla
bridge mm-hmm which is incredibly funny
but maybe only to London
and re-watching fleabag re-watching
episodes I'm just going to fill my brain
with other people's iconic content
that's good yeah
I've been filling my brain with trash
I've been watching nothing about reality
TV lately and so I need love in mind uh
I had that yeah went through that in
like a day I just started watching I
found out about this British dating show
I'm called five guys a week and yeah I
literally I was I went to London a
couple weeks ago for my boyfriend's
birthday and was so desperate to watch
love is blind because we had started it
before we left and they didn't have it
in the UK on the servers over there that
I like downloaded an IP scrambler for my
computer that said that I was in America
when I was over there so I could watch
on Netflix it was very desperate times
but now with that I can get those
British television now and it's five
days a week the premises a woman invites
five guys to sleep at her house for a
week as she figures out which one she
has a love connection oh my god England
British reality television somehow
handles this desperate dating scenario
with more tact than American right
dating show so there's something more
like oh I don't feel the desperation
like seething off of these people right
now there's something a little bit so
everything's tongue also everything
getting in cheek is very direct like
people will say exactly what they're
feeling in a way and these conversations
get handled so quickly rather than these
like passive-aggressive comments that
happen all the time right in
conversations in American totally
despise positivity yeah I appreciate how
direct everyone is because of that I'm
like wow he just said exactly what he
thinks and she responded exactly how she
loved it it's great but our TV like the
way that American people talk about our
reality TV shows when they go over the
[ __ ] I think there was a show called may
be naked attraction okay where if you
put people in booths mm-hm
and so you have I don't know I've never
seen it but I've heard about it at like
10 or 12 booth so I think around and
someone has to choose which person they
want from all these different booths and
how it works as I believe a door comes
up slowly but surely so you're judging
everyone based on their feet then their
knees you're seeing their actual body
then their genitals what people can be
disqualified just based on their
genitals so if someone doesn't have an
attractive vagina or penis my situation
then they can be rejected there and then
and then like the thing has to lift and
they have to walk away like completely
so even if you reject someone they
continue to raise the thing all the way
up so you see their face yeah I will
watch this at least watch it but I also
can't bear it it sounds so absurd some
people get rejected just off of their
tits like oh wow it's just a whole thing
I can't believe that kind of show got
made I know wow it's really amazing
there's so many opportunities for
creativity in the world still okay we're
going to take one last break when we get
back I have a billion Twitter question
there's many good stuff for you your
favorite place put some questions from a
lot of people we'll be right back with
more not your deep sports researchers
your one-stop shop for a lifetime of
performance health and wellness through
the makers of the highest rated collagen
peptide product on Amazon and their
flagship product sweet sweat listen to
this sweating helps burn calories and
sweet sweat activated by your elevated
heart rate helps increase sweating
during exercise you apply the gel which
comes in a variety of pleasing sense too
slow to respond problem areas before
your workout for best results use sweet
sweat in combination with sports
researches best-selling waist trimmers
like their new neon waist trimmer
collection and did you know that
collagen is vital to help support the
health of your skin your hair your nails
and your connective tissues I didn't but
that's why you should try sports
research is third party certified and
non-gmo verified collagen peptides which
provide the best product at the best
price they're offered in a variety of
flavors so sports research collagen
peptides can be added to coffee to soup
to sauces and more at home or on the go
this is all bonkers to me about if
you're interested go try it because
there's a special offer if you go to
sports research calm and use the code
grace at checkout right now you'll get
20% off your order
that's 20% off site-wide at sports
research comm with code grace at
checkout I've done some sweating just
reading the sad read I appreciate so
much your playboy article is fully
dressed and it's just very thoughtful
and tasteful and it's not retouched and
it's just very cool were you surprised
that they agreed to all of these ideas
no because I I am lucky that I'm in a
position of power now where I just don't
do anything and that's okay and my own
way so I was like I will you know I
think what you're doing with this
magazine is really cool I will agree to
do the interview in the photoshoot if I
can shoot it my way yeah no Photoshop in
some suits that I have and just very
natural and like a man and where nothing
is called nothing is showing nothing's
tight nothing is making me feel
self-conscious I just want to be
comfortable and shot like a guy and also
I want to guest edit the entire issue
and they were so cool about it and I had
such an amazing experience picking all
of my favorite creators and writers and
Ashley C Ford did the interview and
Quinta B's in it and Patrick Stewart so
Patrick Stewart's randomly just my my
brain was downloaded to Playboy and we
got to we got to create this wonderful
issue about free speech that's
incredible what an amazing opportunity
yeah and also just like what a powerful
message to have Playboy and this go hand
in hand I think so I think we're all
about progress not perfection I sure as
[ __ ] am because I'm always in progress
that's why I call myself a feminist in
progress and I think that they were
super problematic and
and I think what they've done with their
brand post hue passing away is just so
inspiring and interesting the
conversations they have the articles the
the fact that they let me put I got to
choose my own playmate and I chose a
young a young woman who has one leg so
they have incorporating disability and
it's amazing that positivity and trans
positivity in this new way of a Playboy
sir
cool very cool what a great opportunity
okay before we get into these Twitter
questions I'm going to ask you the two
questions ask every single guest that's
on the podcast
the first is who alive or dead would you
most want to throw cold spaghetti act I
mean currently Boris Johnson okay
leaders of my country miss handling
corona haha horrendously putting loads
of businesses and people in jeopardy and
the safety of our country and totality
and yeah stupid [ __ ] theory on herd
immunity so on a throw cold spaghetti at
Boris Johnson that's good he could still
maintain some social distance while
doing exactly okay the other question is
that
tell us your worst pants [ __ ] story
or a close call but you can only use
three words or three small phrases so
mine is college jogging front lawn okay
mine is like that you have one
immediately oh gold so only three words
or three phrases three words or three
small phrases or some concatenation okay
fine I'm gonna try okay so
shut all over the road for two hours ran
home naked
this sounds like the start of a really
fun like female empowering movie there's
nothing in power it was only degrading
he's also only a couple of years ago
okay you continue to be relatable
again nothing relatable about that story
ran home in America [ __ ] out in my own
[ __ ] Wow again something that builds
your character to a point that the small
[ __ ] won't let for lack of a better word
affect you as much yeah it was a great
perspective yeah you've been through it
yeah okay let's get into these Twitter
questions someone want to know what is a
product or cause that you wish
celebrities would use their platform to
promote mm-hmm
I know what I don't want them to promote
[Laughter]
climate change yeah we should all be
talking about climate change all the
[ __ ] time yeah we should have used
all of our interviews to talk about
mental health and climate change but
right now we're in an emergency yeah
yeah I can't honestly can't believe that
it isn't spoken about more yeah I I
don't know how or why and I'm worried
that it gets pushed aside because the
focus shifts to something else but also
to keep taking their private jet so
they're afraid of being called out for
their blatant hypocrisy but also I guess
there's that new wave of people over the
last four years being like shut up
celebrities we don't want to hear
opinions it's like you hired a reality
TV star as your president you do care
about what celebrities think yeah yes
there's a celebrity in the [ __ ] White
House yeah it's absolutely true it's so
Assessor kazar so yeah the environment
okay someone says you lose a lot of
anonymity when you're famous does
becoming famous so quickly feel like a
shock to your system yes it does
especially if you are an introvert who
never wanted to be famous or wanted to
be in this industry I sort of fell into
this industry so it definitely felt very
invasive and cumbersome but the first
time around when I became famous just in
England it was much worse because I was
pretending to be someone that I wasn't
now that I am being completely myself
all the time and I turn up covered in
food or that looks like I'm covered in
[ __ ] I swear it's not come either way is
this is wow this is really dusty I
haven't bathed like we know you're doing
quarantine correctly I showered this
morning because of this like I haven't
showered the entirety of the week well
that's great but I I guess now that I
don't really feel I have anything to
hide it feels less invasive but it's
definitely strange
especially to have your look scrutinized
that's really instantly yeah yeah
obsessively and especially do you find
that now that you're speaking out you
know positively about bodies that
there's more scrutiny on you physically
or do you know no one does the media
don't dare because I'm so [ __ ]
annoying
my full Ike not my full nipple but some
of my nipple was out in every single
photograph at the Emmys no I mentioned
it no one would dance with me she's out
just peeking over the top just having
her moment in every sink 100% of the
Emmys she's making a political statement
yeah she's baiting us so no no I don't
and also people know I don't care about
their opinion on my looks yeah that is
interesting rate so that you've taken
coming back in a way and so people now
have no need to try and cut you down
they're so strange yeah how that works I
mean it's nice that they don't attack
you anymore yeah nice but at the same
time it takes you having to like stand
up for yourself over and over again to
get them to back off exactly oh okay
given all the philosophy and morals
underlying the writing of the good place
what idea did the show present that is
stuck with you the most the idea there
are two the bigger more philosophical
one is just the clever underlying
message of the good place which which
couldn't be more important right now
which is that you take people from
different walks of life from different
backgrounds with very different
personalities different interests and
different traumas and the only way that
they can
all get to a better place as if they put
their differences aside and work
together hmm and I think that that is an
amazing analogy yeah what the world
needs to do is that in this moment where
we're being so politically divided and
turned against each other and the blame
is constantly being shifted amongst us
rather than at the powers that be we
need to put our differences aside and
stop with the Olympics the hate Olympics
that are going on right now and the
oppression Olympics and this that and
the other we need to we need to be able
to work together and we need to figure
this out because the system that's
supposed to protect us is the one that
is hurting us so we're going to have to
do this ourselves and then also just to
Harney his obsession with other people
liking her was an extra reminder for me
that if I care about other people's
opinions I'll probably end up in hell
so I'm going to hell I'm going on my own
[ __ ] time so that pushed me further
to not care what other people's approval
there must have been oddly therapeutic
then playing this part and being able to
see the dissimilar aspects of it or to
see like the actual like repercussions
played out in this fantasy world yeah
that's very cool in a way which moments
or reactions give you the feeling that
what you're doing is inspiring and
changing people's lives I'm sure I say
that can which moments or reactions I'm
assuming they mean like when people
reach out to you or they react to
something that you've said or work that
you've created
what which ones give you the feeling
that you're doing what you're doing is
inspiring I think I get stopped by women
every day mm-hmm and it's never a
conversation about anything other than
their eating disorder or or how they've
learned to come to terms with their rape
and so I have very very very meaningful
conversations with complete strangers
where they tell me their secrets and and
a girl said to me in a supermarket
recently I started eating again because
of you Wow and so she hadn't been eating
for years just so so thin and was
struggling with anorexia and she burst
into tears and we just had a pre
isolation hug oh when you could still
touch strangers
I think I guess that's the thing yeah we
get a lot of letters I get a lot of
letters and that's nice but there's just
I still don't feel like any of my work
has done there's so much to do and these
just mostly what it is is rather than a
reminder that I'm inspiring it's a
reminder of like how [ __ ] this world
it well do ya and how young some of
these girls are really messes with my
head yeah cuz you're just like oh no you
shouldn't be thinking about this at all
right you're too young there's so many
things you're missing out on right now
my being so imprisoned in your own sake
you as damaged by 13 as I was by the age
of 25 on the Internet so yeah but I
guess that's that's a really nice part
of what I do that's great and I think
that's so helpful for young women to be
able to see that in you even though
there's you know a 10 plus your age gap
there's still like such relatability
what are some things that you miss about
living in the UK oh well I miss the
sweet stuff
I miss our TV because I think we have
wonderful television and I miss my
friends all my friends I'd say 95% of my
friends are people that I met at the age
of 19 really before I was in this
industry and so those are the people
that I really really miss and they're
all still in the UK not all of them I've
slowly but surely dragged everyone so
I'm managing like two friends a year
it's a long plan a long time I love
America and I want to live here for many
years and I just got my green card so
congratulations thank you yeah and so
I'm happy here but I'm gonna need to
find a way to combine both well hey Bill
have more guest rooms in your house and
slowly lower them also afternoon tea if
you ever had British afternoon tea I
have not it is [ __ ] unbelievable I
don't know what about crustless tiny
sandwich yeah that just changes your day
it's only got cucumber and butter in it
and it's just the greatest thing that's
happened it's like a mini orgasm inside
your mouth okay I understand
sophocles the joy can bring it is yeah
there's something very dainty and
delightful about it oh you just feel
like a lucky draw in someone to know
your favorite Taylor Swift song my
favorite Taylor Swift song oh god I
don't know it's my favorite Taylor Swift
song I think that new song if I was the
man I'd be the man is really cool oh
yeah her prosthetics in that music video
we're pretty incredible yeah they're
amazing
I also really like to shake it off yeah
it's my favorite tennis fit the classic
she writes bops yeah I can't deny that
would you rather sweat sunscreen or not
be able to tell the difference between a
muffin and a baby I draw the sweat
sunscreen because I'd eat that babies
babies can eat yes the if you took the
ladder it would create terrible social
situations
yeah but sweating sunscreen [ __ ] love
muffins is super dangerous and will be
very problematic for you okay so easy
easy decision yeah what is your favorite
thing to do on a rainy day um oh I just
want to be the big or little spoon with
my boyfriend I don't mean that sexually
sort of like a clothes on spoon watching
Netflix with him oh that's very nice
there's something very safe and
comforting what's been the harshest
thing someone has ever said to you
online this [ __ ] [ __ ] online started
a rumor that I have Munchausen's yes
peace to get that lot all these
interviews mine over the last 11 years
and put them in this weird order and
took things completely out of context
there was a point where she took two
different car accidents that I had
claimed that they were the same car
accident my two stories about them we're
about the same one accident which makes
me look like a complete that you're just
telling or like a psychotic liar
yeah but they're two different car
accidents 13 years apart just a ablest
[ __ ] who started this rumor that
because
the internet hadn't had any [ __ ] on me
the internet just ran with because they
love a conspiracy theory Monaca Oprah at
the moment yeah Oprah had to address
that that theory I don't I no longer
feel bad for myself after I saw what
Oprah got [ __ ] surreal and Tom Hanks
is now being accused of stuff in like
pizza gate you're just so it's just mad
so but that one hurt because I've been
sick my whole life and so to have my
health my physical health and my mental
health attached like that but also to
know how much that affected other people
with invisible disabilities and also to
watch Munchausen's become a punchline
it's like that's a serious illness yeah
people have that people have to live
with people who have that it's really
scary
yeah and so it's not funny it's not a
joke so that that was the one thing that
read that the only thing that has ever
managed to hurt my feelings but that's
because it like hurt the kid that didn't
know if they were gonna survive to be an
adult right Ray Ray Ray I'm sorry that's
awful
no it was alright I have a list I know
syndromes that we look healthy on the
outside but we are incredibly
accident-prone incredibly injury prone
so it's the same thing and we are
incredibly sick yeah it's when your
phone is since retire I was born with it
yeah okay yeah that's I mean there's so
many invisible diseases that so many
people you know I have a it's just you
know the boxes you in on how you're able
to talk about it cuz you're begging
people to believe you I know and it's
really stressful and even doctors don't
believe some people I'm really lucky I
got I got diagnosed super young so I've
always had people believe me but yeah oh
my god it's crazy yeah so that was the
one thing that I was i I'll [ __ ] you
yeah the internet under that woman yeah
well good stand your ground I mean and
also you're standing up for so many
other people that experience the same
things that face the same like
discrimination in like their actual you
know physicality this was a dumb like
wall might what am i doing what are you
doing what are you taking down here
someone who Oh she's stopping the
teenagers from shaking the lights is
gonna take this [ __ ] down she's
fighting for women's right let's take it
down we to expose this [ __ ] oh no she's
making people feel less
about their suicidal thoughts or their
mental health problems
keeping the teenagers from building a
traumatic emotional scars that they'll
carry for the rest of July lifting back
the curtain on the lives of Hollywood
take a down shooter it nothing stupid
Wow
it's so I mean that's like the classic
Internet of something someone lights
like a piece of black grass on fire and
then a wildfire just starts me doesn't
it you're like I did I what I didn't ask
for this ID no I just saw it going
around on the internet and I was like
Jesus Christ well in line with that
someone wants to know someone says that
she has the same genetic disease and
she'd like to hear about how you deal
with a demanding schedule as well as a
demanding body it's [ __ ] hard yeah
and you have to work twice as hard as
everyone else just to get out of bed in
the morning and I have to put my legs up
against walls throughout the day because
my location by about 11:00 a.m. the
swelling starts every single day whether
I'm on heels or not and you have to be
very very very protective so I won't do
action films or I won't do action
sequences even I don't play any contact
sports I don't work out I just walk
that's all I can do is just walk gently
otherwise I'll dislocate something or
get hurt right my recovery time is like
three terms longer than a normal person
so you have to treat yourself with
cotton wool and you have to not be mad
at your body you have to thank your body
for everything it's doing in spite of
the a-list analyst and rim and you have
to be honest with yourself about your
limitations because if you try and push
past or put a brave face on you will be
punished so badly later on yeah so it is
hard and you just have to think of
yourself as a legend every day for
getting outta bed that's great I mean
that's that is all you can do no no I
feel like you have a lot of those kind
of messages on a way just reminding
people to thank their bodies for yeah
the things you're able to do we're
deliberately never taught to feel
grateful about anything that we have
otherwise we'll stop buying stuff right
stop consuming yes Amos we think we have
enough we'll stop buying great as soon
as we think we don't need to fix
something and what do we need anything
or is Kristen Bell a good kisser I
didn't kiss her behind-the-scenes okay
Paragon of androgyny wants to know
describe your ideal role either in a
series or on big screen and what message
would you want that character to send I
just want to be in anything that Phoebe
wall abridge wrotes any any of her next
observational comedies I would love to
be in and I just want to continue being
a South Asian who doesn't have to play
any South Asian stereotypes oh yeah I
just want to keep breaking new ground
for South Asians and I loved that tehani
got to play the the sort of sex symbol
type ish figure because normally you
don't see a South Asian in that role
that's why I'm so happy for Khmer oh oh
yeah not in my lifetime I've seen a
South Asian man it's amazing up it's
like you know like doing the photo
shoots and men's health and Wolverine
they meant so much to me I was like [ __ ]
we've never seen a superhero who's an
Indian man we've never seen a sex symbol
who's an Indian or Pakistani man sorry
and so that was really that's really
cool very amazing yeah okay last
question except your family or friends
who past or present would you most like
to be in quarantine with oh so except
for my family I'm guys and no family or
friends
yeah past or present would you most like
to be in quarantine with let me think
this is a good question it's such a
joyous good question god there's so many
people here taking this very serious
this is that contract what happened
I think it's Joan Rivers and I know she
was a massive [ __ ] no I think you guys
last survivor you know what even more
than Joan Rivers oh god it's it's a it's
a very good tie between Joan Rivers and
Wanda Sykes those two my favorite women
singers wonder Sykes is a lie yeah I'm
more likely to be able to do this admit
I would quarantine with one with Wanda
Sykes any day of the [ __ ] week
nothing that woman does that doesn't
make me more and more in love with her I
feel like this could be a web series
that happens during the actual car thank
you so much for being here this was so
fun before we wrap up completely every
guest that's on the podcast gets a
personalized fortune cookie from us to
you cool and you can open it little bit
you don't have to eat it obviously got
their fun pray okay okay thank you for
being a guest editor for Playboy as to
really give evidence the lie I read it
for the articles yeah you're bringing it
back we're allowed to say that genuinely
now where can people find the podcast
and everything that you're working on if
they don't already know you can find the
podcast on Earwolf its on stitcher it's
on Apple it's on Spotify it's forever
you get your bloody podcasts and we
start April 3rd amazing and you're just
your name on Twitter everything right my
name Jimmy - Jimmy on Twitter my name is
Jamila Jamila fishel on instagram
because a six year old boy from Syria
took my name well I get for joining
Instagram in 2000 and like 60 minutes
yeah that's it
awesome thank you again so much this was
so fun and we'll see you guys next time
on episode of not too deep goodbye too
deep
Oh deep deep
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer Melissa D
months edited by Shireen Lonnie Eunice
post production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music better help online
counseling offers licensed counselors
who specialized in issues including
depression anxiety complicated
relationships grief trauma and more you
can schedule secure video or phone
sessions with your therapist plus
securely exchange unlimited messages get
professional help when you want it
wherever it's most convenient and you
beautiful listeners will get 10% off
your first month with the discount code
grace that's better help calm slash
grace
[Music]